I'm very happy to be here packed house a
great venue and
but I think a very very important topic
the ethics of artificial intelligence
and with a special focus today what
developers actually should know so my
name is Vince mod I'm originally from
Hungary I grew up in Germany so that's
why I have this nice German accent I
have a background in medicine
neuroscience ethics and data science and
AI I'm a cinematic live researcher
charity which is the largest medical
university in Europe and I'm CEO of AI
for medicine and in both we actually
apply machine learning methods for the
treatment and the prevention of stroke
and of course during this work a lot of
also ethical topics came up and since
then I'm it's one of the topics that I
talk about I will briefly do a rundown
of AI which will be especially given the
crowd today very brief I will introduce
what actually morality and ethics are
and then we're going to talk actually
about the ethics of artificial
intelligence so this is a machine
learning conference so basically what
I've signed up will be very brief that
will might be a few people here to to
whom this is new as you all know most of
you know AI is the field that is trying
to develop intelligent agents
intelligent agents here meaning it's a
very very narrow definition tools that
can do what humans could do so far only
or maybe even better better at them
subfield of this is machine learning
maybe was algorithms which actually can
be used for many many tasks very
importantly given the data that I feed
and the tasks that I want them to do and
the subfield again of this is deep
learning where we use deep artificial
neural nets for for this task now as you
know and this later we will touch upon
this again AI is the bus buzzword
everybody is doing AI nowadays and what
is it usually mean when they say AI they
usually mean machine learning or
specifically sometimes even only deep
learning but why is it such a hype as
you all know the
tools are actually powerful they
actually can do something self-driving
cars sell flying drones most of you
probably talk to your phones and
sometimes you get reasonable answers
recommendation systems computer vision
and actually as I learned yesterday very
very big advances in the last year also
in NLP you should not miss the keynote
of multi-pitch he's gonna have really
cool talk about that you all know and
ruing and I he said famously a is the
new electricity and for a long time I
absolutely didn't like this sentence
until I realized one thing one analogy
that I really like electricity it's
really around us we we don't see it we
just take it as granted we just push a
button it's there it's your big with us
if we don't think a lot about it and as
we can see this is really one of the
problems how these systems will creep
into our lives will touch upon this
later why this is very important
regarding the ethics of AI but first
let's do a recap what is actually
morality and ethics morality is
basically what you believe is right or
wrong what is good or bad behavior this
is what you personally believe and
although it is personal we generally
like to believe that this should be
generally applicable we do like if you
know we like other people who share our
values what could this be
I put here a few very probably could all
agree tell the truth
keep your promises treat others as you
want to be treated be trustworthy but of
course this is also about more abstract
topics all of you have an opinion if
it's okay or not about abortion animal
testing meat consumption or you know
human cloning how do we get now from
morality to ethics let's imagine a very
very simple conversation he says I'm
against animal testing I think it's
immoral and she will ask a very simple
question she will ask why so the moment
we have to analyze systematize question
morality then we have reached ethics
because
have to find frameworks with which we
can decide which morality is the best in
a given situation which one is justified
and this is what the field of ethics
part of philosophy does let's look at an
example there is an ethical framework
which is called utilitarianism very
briefly it says the most moral choice is
always the one that will produce the
greatest good for the greatest number of
people let's look at an example some of
you might be familiar with this this has
been a thought experiment in philosophy
for a very long long while this is the
so called trolley problem it's a very
sadistic problem because somebody tied
five people to attract actually in total
six five people to attract and the
trolley will inevitably take the
straight way and kill five people you
are the person at the lever you can
change the lever then the trolley will
be diverted and it will kill only one
person according to utilitarianism the
most small choice is clear you have to
push the lever because one person dying
is better than five people die other
frameworks might decide differently this
was just an example but we will see how
this old thought experiment actually has
a modern analogy in our new modern world
and with this we come to the ethics of
artificial intelligence why is this
important as we just saw AI will lead to
autonomous decision-making instead of
humans this is AI agency and it's
already starting to be around us and a
very very good example here that we can
look at is the example of self-driving
cars so imagine this car is on the road
and suddenly due to whatever reason
there are many people on this road now
the car can measure everything it can
measure the distance it can it knows how
long the braking distance will be and it
could realize I will run into these 10
people but there is another choice the
car can also divert to the sidewalk
problem is there is one person on the
sidewalk so what should the car do
should
cargo straight killed potentially many
people oh shoot it divert to the
sidewalk potentially killing less what
what is better you can also imagine
other this was a you can also imagine
other scenarios and be that might be an
easier because there might even be more
passengers in the car buts a similar
scenario there is a person on the road
the car could divert but nowadays a wall
so now you as the driver / passenger are
the one that is actually here in danger
now you could say okay where it's
one-on-one so of course then hit the
person on the road but what again if
there are many people on the road you
were alone there are ten people on the
road so this is actually point and I
hope it's gonna work because yesterday
didn't where I'm gonna ask you a few
questions
so take out your smartphones please and
go to WWNT calm now you can't see it
right second okay now you should see it
okay great
so you should go to WWNT calm and use
the code which you can see there and
then you should see that question i hope
which is an autonomous car should save
as many lives as possible or protect the
driver or the passengers
it's still filling up quickly so we wait
a bit
seems people are motivated they see that
you know so many people have voted so
they world themselves but we're kind of
reaching slowly a plateau right so we
have we have you know we have a slight
tendency in the audience to words
utilitarianism save as many lives as
possible okay this is the next question
I'm going to ask you and be honest would
you buy a car that would potentially
kill you to save other people hey where
are all the utilitarian ist's they they
left the premises so I gave a similar
talk yesterday at the human tech meeting
and it was similar results and I have to
say this this high number of nodes is
really so far exclusive to Poland so it
seems that aren't many utilitarian is
generally here
80% yesterday said no so it's usually
it's it's around 60 in other places but
the tendency the tendency is the same I
hope it will now switch back immediately
so I just give you another example this
was another place for us this this was
actually in Berlin it was 7230 in the
first round and then it switched to 260
percent so as you can see it is very
very it is very very simple to say
something abstractly but then the
morality or idea might change very
quickly when actually realized hey that
also affects myself and I didn't come up
with these questions this was actually a
publication in science in 2016 the
social dilemma of autonomous vehicles
for exactly this was shown and since
then I have replicated this in every
talk where I asked this it's again
people are generally in favor of it but
no not if it's not if it's about me and
this is really a problem because if
there is a I agency around us we need to
decide what morality this AI should have
and obviously we're not even sure
ourselves what that actually could be
because within 20 seconds you answered
the question differently
so which morality should these these
tools actually have we don't know and I
don't want to touch about it long but
just when I mentioned of course this is
tied to all the questions of who is
responsible if something wrong with
transparency do you actually even know
about these decisions and all these
problems I'm going to give now several
more examples of ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence I want to start
Anna touched upon this when I said AI is
a buzzword what is AI exactly it's not
defined so how do you want to actually
regulate something that is not defined
you make a law about something and you
write we regulate artificial
intelligence and somebody said yeah but
this isn't even AI what I'm doing so if
it's ill-defined you cannot even
regulate it or make an ethical framework
about this is a real problem if you look
at regulatory frameworks each one tries
to come up with their own definition
sometimes broad so this already in
itself is an ethical problem a really
big ethical problem and I want to talk
about this the longest from the ethical
problems is AI by
as you probably all know what is AI bias
it's a systematic deviation of the of
what system actually should do
systematic deviation in the output let's
look at a few examples so this was an
actual tool from Google that you could
use to label your photos it was good in
labeling skyscrapers airplanes cars
bikes ouch you should probably not label
like people as gorillas this was not a
good tool and Google had to take that of
course offline let's look at another
example this is the Turkish language
which is regarding this this thing that
I want to tell you about very similar to
the Hungarian language you have this we
have the sentence which was translated
by Google Translate - he is a doctor you
might ask yourself what is the problem
the problem is that these first two
words which indicate this are not a
specific it's like in Hungarian it can
mean he she or it and if you put in
another sentence to translate suddenly
it's translated to she is a nurse so the
translating to somehow learnt is biased
at the moment it's about a doctor of
course that person must be male and if
it's a winner nurse that person must be
female now of course this is not a bias
and Google actually fixed this so if you
do it now you get the right translation
that it could mean she is a doctor he is
a dr. Hungarians were still
discriminated because in Hungarian it's
still like this if you put it in
Hungarian hit still only he is a doctor
now where does this a high bias come
from the algorithms in machine learning
itself you all know they are agnostic
they they don't introduce bias if
there's bias the bias comes from the
data that's a good example from from
healthcare this was a paper from startup
in Toronto and they could show that
actually they could predict the onset of
Alzheimer's with a relatively high
accuracy just by recording a person's
speech
this was very nice there's just one
little problem at least the first
version this was the only place in the
world where this tool could be used and
why because they trained this this model
exclusively on people from Toronto so
the only speech pattern that this tool
actually could understand was the
English dialect of Toronto and this is
very prominent in healthcare and I just
want to show this this is a overview of
genomic studies until 2009 and 2016 and
as you can see the overwhelming majority
of these studies we're done on people of
European descent so if you develop any
predictive tool on genomic data on this
data it will only be applicable to
people of European descent and will have
a huge bias if applied to other people
one of the most problematic by assistent
can creep into our systems is actually
cognitive bias so what does that mean
let's do a thought experiment
we are now attack giant of you know it's
effective Jack Attack giant and we
realize one thing we realize we actually
pay a lot of money for recruiting people
right
you'll probably all know that online
interviews on site interviews people
have flown through the world for
font-size its costs a lot of money we
could save a lot of money if we you know
trained a model that can take a CV and
then just say this is a good candidate
or this is a bad candidate we could save
a lot of money so why don't we do that
because we're a tech giant and we
actually have our company data right we
have all the data from the last I don't
know how many years of our hiring and we
assume be great at hiring so let's let's
take that data so could there be bias in
it let's have a look could there be
gender bias in it probably yes which
gender biases do we know that affect
hiring affinity bias it's a cognitive
bias we tend to like people who are
similar to us
if you have a workforce where they're
mostly males then there is already a
cognitive bias that you don't want to
change that structure intergroup bias
it's also called a cultural fit bias
it's like people from the same you know
university from the same background like
each other and there is a certain you
know as probably all know male geeky
culture that sometimes is prevalent in
this field which is not so easy than for
for others to fit in confirmation bias
is a cognitive bias which is a problem
here if you are already if you believe
that it's better to hire certain people
in this case this case males then if a
female does something wrong it will say
of course we shouldn't have hired hairy
females is something wrong yeah he
basically just had a bad day so we just
confirmed what we already believe
there's the horn effect which really
means like having horns like the devil
so this means that we see something
physically on a person some feature and
believe that this person must be for
example bad at this job
one example is here obesity it's shown
that obese people are thought to
actually be worse at their jobs and it's
also shown scientifically that this
disproportionately affects women and
basically almost as an overview of these
days gender stereotyping meaning that as
we saw in the example that I saw if it's
a doctor must be male if it's nurse and
must be fear she must be female and if
we talk about a programmer programmer
must be male right no of course not but
this is exactly the cognitive bias so
taking all this together without to work
well this wasn't a thought experiment
some of you might have read about this
it was reported that Amazon just
recently had to actually kill a tool
where they tried to because they
couldn't get the bias out of their own
hiring data they used their own hiring
data to build such a tool and they
couldn't get the bias against women out
of the tool of course they didn't put
in gender but even something the moment
the tool was so tuned discriminate
against women the moment it found that
somebody attended female university that
person was out so they actually pulled
the plug which is good other companies
won't and already in 2016 it was
reported that 72 percent of resumes at
least in the US but weeded out before a
human ever saw them and this is not only
a problem this was now gender bias but
we can assume that hiring in the past
data they produced there was
discrimination not only against women
that might have been discrimination
against poor people against migrants and
so forth and so forth not a problem
unregulated ai development in AI and you
know how fast it is is basically faster
than legislation this is what I strongly
believe and politics as you all know
lack the knowledge they have no idea
about artificial intelligence and our
democratic processes are likely too slow
to keep up with this so this will be a
huge challenge we will be confronted a
lot with systems that don't match any
regulation which are not regulated so
this this will be a huge ethical
challenge in the future how do we deal
with this there is also the problem of
ethics shopping if AI is a market driver
there will be different levels of
regulation throughout the world so it is
very likely that companies but also
governments others will try to up do
shopping so they will go where they get
what they want and they might get a tool
from somewhere where the ethical
standards are much lower than where the
ones we have how do we deal with this
are we still using it knowing that this
might have been you know developed let's
say in China what is not talked so much
about which I believe is a very very big
ethical challenge is ai manipulation as
probably many of you know these systems
don't exactly
you know work like basically our brains
work it's very easy to take the image of
a cat just change a few pixels and then
suddenly the output of your model is
toaster and not yet anymore although to
us the image still looks like a cat and
it's very easy to assume that you know
bomb scanning systems could be fooled
insurance fraud could be committed and
actually already has been shown that
just very very subtle manipulations of a
street sign make the street sign
actually invisible for an autonomously
driving car so of course we need
robustness against this kind of
manipulation otherwise we have a huge
ethical challenge we just pretended to
be a tech giant but as you all know many
of the powerful light was actually in
the hands of the real existing tech
giants and how do we make sure that
actually what they develop is
responsible we had in Berlin in June an
event together with Google where the
head of the responsible development team
of Google presented what they do
internally and to be honest that was
really good
the problem here is what if the next CEO
of Google five years ten years just
decides we don't need that anymore
we don't need responsible development so
it cannot be that responsible
development is dependent on the whims of
the CEO of a new CEO so taken together
we have big challenges regarding these
ethical challenges which are some of
them are technical you're gonna talk
later a bit about it what we can do from
the technical side but of course there
is also big from from society side and
why is that because if we take this now
together we're basically right now at
the crossroads regarding this technology
if we develop tools on unbiased data the
overall bias in our societies will go
down why is that because a person who is
potentially biased will use an unbiased
tool so we have actually the possibility
to decrease bias in many places imagine
an unbiased recruiting
suddenly more people would be hired and
a murder and what diverse you know
hiring would happen if you do it wrong
however and we just take all our biases
and ultimate eyes them basically and put
them in tools then we will increase bias
because even the unbiased person will
now actually use a bias tool so we will
have more bias in our societies and this
is really the crossroads where we're at
the moment and one of the things that we
really need here I'm strongly believe is
a public discussion we need more public
eye illiteracy we need public discussion
and this also especially means that
experts most of you are experts
regarding this technology also should
really first be aware of the ethical
implications and also go out and talk to
others and this is very very important
because I mentioned government's
regarding regulation but government's
the moment they will understand this
technology better and some governments
already understood it there is a threat
that if the public doesn't understand
how these things work there might be a
threat even to the fabric to the main
fabric of our society to democracy
itself ok let's take a deep breath now
the world is not going to end although
it sounded a bit like it so let's look
at solutions that the solutions now are
tied to also to the title of the talk to
the subtitle what developers should know
what are potential solutions that we can
actually use here it's very very
important to get away from what I like
to call the Kaggle mentality ah there's
a data set somebody prepared this data
set now I start with the fun part with
the predictive modeling it's definitely
the fun part right I mean maybe some of
you are passionate data Wranglers some
people are but in the end we have to
have a culture where we say data needs
always to be questions what is the
source is there bias in the data
and one really important thing here is
also you need a workforce that is more
diverse that also it could be that more
aware of these biases if you think back
to this to this tool of Google where
suddenly black people were labeled as
gorillas it's probably likely that it
more diverse work for somebody would
have realized hey we have only you know
just a few labels for black people that
might be a problem will probably not
work well it must be in the training to
AI engineers who could really be trained
in the s in understanding source of bias
but also in often the ethical
implications if I ask around now P you
know people who did a master's in AI
universities they said we've never
talked about this at all it was only
focused really on it was focused really
on on only the technical parts ethical
implications were and bias implications
were not even mentioned I think this
should really change and there are when
it said data of course it could be data
source but if we actually think this
through of course any step in the data
preparation or in the data analysis
process can introduce bias it can be in
the data already it can be introduced in
the data wrangling process it can be
introduced in a sub selection of the
data and data labeling is a big problem
so all these steps actually can lead in
itself to bias and during the
development process engineers need to be
a varied there is the possibility to the
bias data so as you probably know there
are many also companies who work
actually on tool boxes that can help you
to actually devise your data there
should be guidelines for companies I
mentioned I mentioned Google the
responsibility so you you killed you
should have so companies that develop AI
they should have internal responsible
development guidelines this should be
something that a company has
there's also the problem we talked about
development but there is of course also
research we need reporting guidelines
I'm not sure how many of you are aware
that in AI research we have abysmal II
bad scientific quality how often have
you read maybe a paper and you realize
the information there is not even you
know remotely enough for me to reproduce
this but the hallmark of science is rip
you disability you need to be able to do
exactly what the person did it should be
a cookbook now like with any recipe you
might have to try once or twice but in
the end you should be able to replicate
this if you can't replicate this it's
bad science it's very simple and part of
it is having reporting guidelines that
other fields that clearly say ok what
needs to be reported so that I can
understand this and I can reproduce this
we don't have it there was recently I
saw that somebody in an archive there
was a paper that suggested model cards
and that is actually be nice thing I
really liked it for you basically in
every publication should have a model
card which is a which is a reporting
guideline which says these are the
things you should report about your
model we should adapt that right
so in the medical field this was
understood there are now reporting
guidelines at least suggested for
clinical trials that use artificial
intelligence but of course this is not
exactly the same so we need and this
must be a community effort because only
the experts can decide what needs to be
inside these reporting guidelines now of
course we need ethical frameworks that
are especially tailored to this that
there are not really ones that people
have agreed on and we need regulation so
both the FDA but also European Union
have started to work on such guidelines
so the European Union just published
recently the ethics guidelines for
trustworthy AI so this is something that
is publicly available that maybe you
also should read or it would be a nice
read
but again these have not found their way
yet into any type of regulation and
interestingly that means that a field
like healthcare I come from is the field
where is concerned because we already
have regulation if you want to build a
medical product built on machine
learning it's a medical product it's a
medical device you have to go through
medical device regulation and yes the
regulator's at the moment have no idea
about this technology but they will have
to because they were confronted with it
and for example the so called notified
bodies which do these check of the
systems they were closely so in Germany
they were closely with an institute that
is very that knows a lot about medical
devices they for example know a lot
about AI they will probably adapt very
soon the guidelines from this institute
and those guidelines are pretty heavy
and they really really know what AI is
about so there is not a problem but what
about the fields where there is no
regulation you're probably aware that in
in the u.s. already they use artificial
intelligence systems judges use
artificial intelligence systems to
determine how big the likelihood is that
somebody will commit a crime in the
future by the way these systems are
completely biased in this in this area
we have no regulation and there are many
other areas where we have no regulation
so we need this regulation in these
areas and at least I'm convinced about
it now what is this I come to this point
and this I would like to explain so we
talked about morality and ethics now
there is a different word which is
called the ethos now what is an ethos
the ethos is basically the morality of a
group as you probably know physicians
I'm medicine was my first study
physicians have an ethos there are
certain things which a doctor shouldn't
do and they are not forbidden by law
it's just things that a physician
shouldn't do it's codified by the
morality of doctors so if a physician is
basically violating this ethos the
Asians themselves you know the chamber
of physicians can revoke their license
so that person will not be able to
legally practice medicine anymore they
might not have to basically break a law
for this but there is an ethos that
doctors do don't do certain things so
this is the morality of a profession and
I strongly believe or I maybe I
suggested maybe especially a crowd and
this could be also something we can
discuss that maybe there should exist
something like a developer Zephyrs
something that you as a community of
developers basically a codified morals
that you decide you say the moment we
develop certain systems there are things
we should do and other things we just
won't do there are certain tools which
should not be developed and now right
now it's easy to say but that was my job
I was I was paid for it I got the data I
did it what's what's happening with it
it's not my problem I think that is too
easy if these systems are actually have
such a big impact of society you have
reached the level of doctors because
your actions actually have a big impact
on the lives of people so maybe you
should have such an ethos yourself and
you should have a chamber of AI
developers that is actually checking
this and realizing what is what is moral
so to say AI coding and with this
thought I would like to thank you for
your attention
okay do you have a question to Vince we
have support for one question no
questions I'm around today so you can
always approach me and ask questions
thanks a lot
oh there's one question on the back
first question of the conference takes
time
great presentation thank you I'd like to
ask one question you mentioned that the
government and regulation do not are not
following the speed of development of AI
isn't that our responsibility to explain
to the people who don't understand what
it is I mean I I think this is more like
we should be like like we know more so
we should explain we should put a lot of
effort into explaining government what
it's what it is all about and not
complaining about that isn't that how it
should be absolutely I think I mentioned
when I said publicly illiteracy that I
really think those who know I would
almost say have a more responsibility to
teach others yes absolutely I agree okay
there was one here as well
no all right thank you so much fees
thanks a lot big opposed
yes Romero oh you have a question sorry
I'm Samuel Greek with Nielson and my
question is do you think that if we
don't come up with our own ethos so I
can't you put the mic but do you think
that if we don't come up with our own
ethos that potentially governments or
other bodies will come up with the ethos
for us and do you think that we're more
capable of coming up with a better ethos
than those government bodies so I would
answer it like this there will be
regulation I'm pretty sure about this so
it's the same as in the medical field
there's various regulation which means
there are laws and basically the ethos
will sometimes overlap with the law but
there will be again parts which which go
beyond beyond the laws so I think this
is where we're the place of really often
of an ethos is of course you will be
able to somehow influence regulation
because at least I hope politics will
ask the people that actually they're
actually involved in this but I think
that really needs to be this this this
ethos as well because otherwise I really
think that there was a reason why fields
you know like lawyers like physicians
started having this because the impact
was so strong so I really think that
that this is this especially so whether
law ends the the ESO ethos should start
this is kind of what I mean but but but
didn't the ethos in those industries
come before the laws did they knew how
to organize themselves before
for example the government's knew how to
organize them so they made their effort
to regulate themselves as far as I
understand it before the governments
came in and mandated things that didn't
make sense for them because the
government's just don't have that level
of knowledge like right
certainly it could it could be that way
if you if you start early enough then a
lot of this will actually become a law
that also makes sense from from from
from your side from the developers side
and then there must will be less
iterations over wait that went too far
this didn't make sense I agree
okay thank you so much